the owner of a Colorado daycare center
and preschool faces criminal charges
including child abuse following a
six-week investigation Karla faith is
accused of hiding neglected children
behind a false wall in her home three
other women have also been charged Don
Dahler is here with us with more so Don
what else do we know well we know this
case started back in mid-november
Colorado Springs police showed up at the
daycare center after receiving
complaints that it was housing too many
children for what it's licence said now
what they found when they got there was
far more disturbing on November 13th
Colorado Springs officers pulled up to
this home owned by 58 year old Carla
faith they were conducting a welfare
check on children she was supposed to be
taking care of at her daycare play
mountain place when officers first
arrived they say they found no children
and that faith refused to cooperate but
then they heard children's voices and
after investigating found a false wall
inside the building behind it a basement
with two adults and 26 children all
under three years old according to the
arrest affidavit officers reported
finding most of the children sweating
visibly dehydrated with wet or soiled
diapers saying don't take me to the
little house don't meet eight until up
don't put me downstairs CBS affiliate
station Kate KTV spoke to parents of
children in faith care after the
facility was shut down in November we
all feel completely betrayed it's so
hard to trust your children with people
and we felt like we could really trust
them police arrested Carla faith
christina swagger katlyn Nelson and
Valerie Fresquez for child abuse faith
swagger and Nelson were also charged
with felonies for other crimes related
to the case but the consequences
extended beyond the day care faith also
ran a preschool nearby and when police
closed it nearly two dozen teachers lost
their jobs we weren't actually
associated with anything going on at
play mountain and that's the hardest
part was we're getting punished I didn't
even get to say goodbye to most of my
kids faith actually owned four childcare
facilities in all of Colorado Colorado
Springs all of them have been shut down
the Colorado Department of Human
Services
says she previously ran childcare
facilities in California that were shut
down for similar reasons now parents who
left their children in her care have now
filed a lawsuit claiming breach of duty
of care it seems unbelievable that this
could have happened in one state and now
here and and she'd be able to get
licensed again yeah it was so strange
the police showed up after reports that
there were too many children there and
she initially told them that there were
no kids in the building and then she
said oh they're all playing at a park
but they took the initiative went inside
to investigate and this is what they
thought like that woman said that's the
hardest part is trusting your children
with someone else really is not knowing
if they're doing the right thing
sometimes
no all right Don Dahler for us thank you
you